(slow guitar music)
In Peru it is very common
that archaeological sites
are surrounded by
local communities,
villages, towns,
where people live
usually in the most
traditional ways.
Pachacamac is a
huge archaeological
site south of Lima.
Around it we have
three million people
living in shanty towns,
in one of the poorest
sectors of Lima,
always threatening to encroach
and jump into the site.
We need to engage with
them and interact with them
in ways in which they feel
that this site is not
subtracting from them
but is adding to their lives.
Local communities
can and should be
the first line of defense
for these archaeological sites
that are not only part
of their heritage but,
if properly
developed, like here,
they can become sources
of income for them.
(soft piano music)
SPI stands for Sustainable
Preservation Initiative.
This is an initiative
that started
with archaeologists interested
in developing better means
to protect cultural heritage.
We have now six
programs around Peru
in different communities in
the highlands and the coast.
What we do is we
have engaged women
that live around the sites.
These women are some of
the most traditional people
living in the coast of Peru.
(woman giggling)
(upbeat music)